[Music]
thank you
ah finally something comfy
let's slip something comfy on what do
you say yeah yes lion yep big gay lion
word there that doesn't sound generic
but I would say
I can think of words outside of the word
lovable that would describe Mike Perry
but
donated five dollars thick Papa talking
about B ultimately there's like just
something about his openness and
his way with words he feels authentic I
guess is what I'm trying to say and
when people are authentic and
self-deprecate or like speak openly I
guess because even self-deprecation
that's often more
calculated
what pseudo-intellectual again I know I
use that term a lot but he really is
fake smart guys this is why I will
always respect people like Michael
Strahan who just know what they are and
they act like what they are this guy is
trying so I don't know what he's running
from he's running from himself
but he says he sounds like a [ __ ]
motivational speaker
it's also am I the only one to is it
just me or are the letters getting more
crooked I think at this point every time
he slams the table it shakes the letters
because remember that's not a real ball
behind him that's one of those faux
walls that they move so the letters
probably shake the elves for sure are
off now the L's for sure are off but
then say totally keeps tilting downward
like he started the say on the level
with the L's yeah so that just bothers
me you know why you know why the letters
are moving because they don't let him
keep his set up they make him break it
down after he didn't feel me I think
he's I know I think he might be right
because I bet you that that just moves
right
it's more like I have these set of jokes
about myself that I can you know like
when I'm doing you know when I write
these jokes for like hey that hurts and
pretend like these hate it's like that's
well within this confines of like I'm
making fun of myself physically in a way
that isn't actually vulnerable you know
what I mean it's already out there it's
not like I'm exposing like a secret
about myself that you know it took up a
lot of courage to sort of admit and and
be honest and that actually risks other
people judging me for it and
when you're talking to Mike Perry I feel
like you're always on the verge of like
getting something where you're like wow
like
I don't know man I I'm trying to really
understand
I don't know man this guy sucks he is
it is exhausting we keep it thick with
this midday ice cream sandies
what 280 views
280 views man
again it doesn't yeah so it's like
in any great movie you're gonna find
something like that because it's just
there's so many stories so does he just
think like he's another one of these
guys that thinks I'll just do my show
and people are gonna tune in well
because the thing is with this show he
just I don't know we've watched enough
of his shows right
I don't know what
the point of him is like
if it was a workout show fine let's say
he was just doing workout stuff right
okay fine he's a workout guy
but then he goes into philosophy and
he's stupid he tries to do comedy but
he's not funny like what and then even
with the stuff he should be good at
which is like working out he's just
telling people to [ __ ] inject dark
web steroids into their dick holes you
know what I mean
well it's because he's an N person
yeah he is you're an Espress yeah stop
saying that bro I am a special because
what he said it's that was his stupid
analogy I remember but that's not how
you mean it I'm an N person so I buy
things illegally on the internet like
drugs like wait what
huh
hey Mark I don't know what you think you
meant by that
well I was I thought I thought this very
interesting
available
this guy more plates more dates who's an
actual Fitness guy yeah he's great did
you see him reacting to uh no that's
[ __ ] amazing did he yeah yeah there's
a specific okay try it around here we go
no you might it might just not be in the
cards for you kind of got famous for
like um he put his Cycle online and he
was like I take 3 000 milligrams of test
anything two thousand of tests like
first one 300 first off can I start with
something right off the bat Brendan
doesn't understand what he's with Mark
Carly saying 300 milligrams of test
isn't that much for a bodybuilder it's
actually a very low amount for a body
but it's high for trt
but it's low but Brendan already he Mark
Carly gonna said 100 milligrams of tests
which is under like what you would have
normally and Brandon would have still
been like wow whoa that's a lot dude
the amount you're going this is not just
like twice what somebody could take and
get results you're taking oh yeah so
this guy holy [ __ ] he is he's like 24
years old or something like that he's
only 24. and if you see his before picks
the dude was if you could do Eric
kneskey before and after so that's not
he yeah I actually did a video breaking
down this like [ __ ] Apocalypse of a
cycle which was [ __ ] Apocalypse of a
cycle
this is this guy Rules by the way
breaking down this Apocalypse of a cycle
yeah because I think you skipped ahead
so I don't know if everybody's gonna
know what he's talking about so you're
talking about because Mark Harley said
that yes yes I probably lost 100
milligrams a day every day every day 10
days right right so he's like this
Apocalypse of a cycle multiple grams of
[ __ ] and it's like you know the summary
of it was basically I think he could
have got away with a lot less and
achieved the same outcome like even
though in the dose response studies the
limited ones we have available you'll
find that you know in general a higher
dose leads to a higher lean body mass
pretty clear when guys abuse the [ __ ]
out of themselves and the grams of gear
territory and don't necessarily like
five extra results just by doing that
detail this cycle
like 20 units of growth hormone a day
300 milligrams
and he looks like [ __ ] on stage that he
will never win a bodybuilding
competition if you look at that picture
it'll win my body comes
what does that even mean Brennan shut up
just just shut up
here you don't know what you're talking
about Brendan it's like about dude for
like YouTube videos I'm saying not to
knock his his like uh you know what he
did to get there but he doesn't have
that that's only genetics two years dude
that's eight years he was like he was
probably so
that was only eight years October 2011
to June 2017. how many years is that
that's six years okay what did he say
what did he say like eight ten no no so
that so so you know it's six years right
okay cool yeah so what he did to get
there but he doesn't have that that's
only genetics two years dude that's
eight years
six he doesn't math well
hey
he doesn't comprehend anything well
eight years to that massive amount I'm
talking again because he's an idiot
sometimes the amount that somebody's
genetics could take and get great
results from right all that stuff scares
me I just want to work out so that's the
route you want to take if you want to be
a WWE guy and you're skinny or like now
he's like a YouTuber and I think he's a
good dude I'm just like
people thought he was like exaggerating
what he took it's like no because if you
don't know the genetics you just have to
keep cranking it and there's diminishing
returns too you think 20 units of HGH is
going to be better like is twice as good
at 10 no it's about this much better and
even sometimes you get to these dosages
and it's like you end up spinning your
wheels and or actually getting worse
results you end up having such dramatic
organ stress and or insulin resistance
and or and you burn out your Androgen
receptor so then the next time you try
to do a normal normal low dose your body
your body's like now no this is nothing
I'm not used to this
that's why even if I was going to do trt
I would ease into it it's like I can
always I always treated like anything
whether it's Adderall or any medications
or like you ease into it well I mean you
hear more later like even if you would
take pain pills because you blew out
your back or you got a surgery right
like you go home and you're like
let me take one it said I could take two
if I need them but like let's take one
and if it still hurts same thing with
like doing regular drugs you'd be like
you know there's people that eat way too
much drugs right away and you're like
slow down you can always take more later
if you're not getting the desired result
well here's the thing if you get trt and
you do it the right way they do the
blood work and everything they're only
going to give you a a manageable amount
they'll never give you more because the
doctors aren't gonna [ __ ] you know
they're gonna give you like probably 160
to 200 milligrams a week that's what
they'll probably tell you they'll give
you something like that but you're not
going to be taking like a bodybuilder
thing was like I don't [ __ ] dudes
that were taking like 500 milligrams of
tests and 400 milligrams of trend and
then anavar and then wind straw and I'm
like bro and you're dead and exactly at
what cost you know what I mean at what
[ __ ] cost